[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here have you
ever heard of Oppo OPP Oh probably not
they're a phone manufacturer based in
China they are doing amazing things
right now that almost no one is talking
about so I wanted to bring up one of
their latest creations but first they
are not a one-hit wonder let's take a
look at one of the other things that
they've done recently the Oppo finder
was their previous creation and despite
what Apple tells you the finder is
actually the thinnest smartphone in the
world by a lot it's six point six five
millimeters thin to give you perspective
the Droid Razr is 7.1 and the iPhone 5
is I think seven point six so the Oppo
finder is a ridiculously thin phone and
they also released the world's thinnest
quad-core smartphone - and now Oppo has
done it again they've announced and
unveiled the world's first 1920 by 1080
smartphone I'll let that sink in for a
second I'll give you a second yeah 1080p
okay yeah okay perspective the iPhone 5
has a 4-inch 326 PPI display the new
phone called the Oppo find which is what
it's called has a 5-inch 441 PPI display
that's 35 percent higher pixel density
that's 2.8 five times the number of
pixels on the iPhone 5 screen that is
absolutely ridiculous but that's not all
it's more than just a pretty face it
ships with the latest and greatest in
hardware and software it ships with
Android 4.1 jelly bean pretty impressive
inside is the latest quad-core
Snapdragon s4 chip which just about
destroys every other chip on the market
right now it has two gigabytes of RAM a
2,500 million power battery expandable
storage and a 12 megapixel camera
okay are you getting all this money okay
so a lot of people will say that your
eyes won't actually be able to tell the
difference between like a 1080p
smartphone and one that's slightly less
but you'll definitely be able to tell
which one is the better-looking the
phone when you put them side-by-side I
know not a lot of people have 1080p
screens in their house that they can
compare this to but we're talking TV
size resolution shrunk all the way down
past a desktop all the way down past a
laptop all the way down past the
Transformer Pad Infinity tablet to a
five inch phone yeah that's awesome I
have high hopes for phones like this and
for companies like this to be noticed
when they're really innovating when some
other companies aren't doing exactly the
same thing so Oppo has done some crazy
things in the past with their thin thin
smartphones and their incredibly
disturbingly high-end specs in
innovation everywhere but I really hope
that this project gets some attention
seriously worldwide also if you're
curious if you want some video of the
Oppo finder which was the six point six
five millimeter smartphone there are a
couple videos of it on YouTube so I'll
leave a link to a pretty good one down
below that's also pretty awesome phone
but that's been out for a little while
this 1080p smartphone is the first one
that I've actually thought that I
actually really want to get there's no
date or pricing or release information
out there just yet
but I mean isn't this a phone that you
also want to get you can leave a thumbs
up if you agree or leave a comment and
we can discuss it I'm answering the
comments down below this is a phone that
I'm excited to see this is a company
that's based in China so obviously I'm
not expecting it to be immediately
readily available worldwide or in the
United States for that matter
but I'm definitely definitely excited
for this project so either way it's the
Oppo find make sure you write it down
remember the name it's gonna be big and
I'll talk to you guys in the next video
which should be the collaboration of all
these setup tours that I've been
collecting on YouTube over the past day
or so so stay tuned for that if you're
excited for it and I'll talk to you guys
in that next video
[Music]
you